[Music]  the only person you can either be in the  town of Greendale where it always feels  like Halloween there lifts a girl who is  half witch half mortal who on her 16th  birthday would have to choose between  two worlds the witch world of her family  and the human world of her friends and  that girl is me  are you  can't you must  I stand alone uh Sabrina you're going to  die half-breed  girls girls that's no big catty [ __ ]  your rebels phone it's our lack colleges  [Music]  I'm not an evil person  but these are desperate times  my name is Sabrina Spellman and I will  not sign it away  would you like to do the honors with  pleasure  right  safety was on Hilda she annoyed me so I  killed her  we buried her in the yard  [Music]  you